[Musique]
une belle robe 1 et puissant un style
des saveurs fruitées la mousse attirant
berry et pas uniquement les spécialistes
aujourd'hui elle s'apprécie avec la même
rigueur que le vin bière qui roule
n'amasse pas mousse
[Musique]
ce soir ces dégustations ludique aux
berrichons
au programme des blanches des brunes des
américaines des allemandes des
classiques aux bouteilles les plus
inédites
le dégustateur sont là pour apprendre et
surtout pour apprécier
la légende voudrait qu'un jour des
chasseurs cueilleurs et laisser une
jarre en terre cuite rempli de serre et
à l'eau à l'air libre en dehors avec les
intempéries
l'eau est rentrée dans la jarre qui est
une fermentation naturelle c'est fait
ils sont revenus nous retrouver il y
avait des petites bulles ils ont goûté
ils ont ressenti l'ivresse alors là il
faut imaginer une dr à 0,5 un degré
d'alcool plutôt une soupe de céréales
tiédasse que une bière telle qu'on la
connaît actuellement sous l'oeil et les
papilles averti de francis leu zito log
la dégustation se poursuit en monologue
de la bière il présente schémas
graphiques et petite anecdote au public
de néophytes
c'est en faisant un peu de chimie et un
brin d'histoire que nos dégustateurs
appréhende la mousse c'est assez
surprenant
la diversité des bières qu'ils peuvent
et qui peut y avoir cité des bières les
goûts les couleurs
[Musique]
tenez que tu ne vis un petit peu novice
on n'imagine pas la diversité c'est une
dégustation on sait qu'on dit tu vas où
on aime y en a quand même ne la connaît
- quoi on retrouve des similitudes
je dirais dans l'est dans les parfums
dans les arômes dans les choses comme ça
là on n'a pas encore goûté d'être
exotique mais il ya des reins ont peu
goûté on peut percevoir des arômes de
fruits exotiques des arômes florales des
choses comme ça donc quelque part on
trouve un peu là c'est très marquée
c'est un peu plus facile si le parallèle
avec le vin est récurrent sécu sur ces
terres traditionnellement viticole le
pli est difficile à prendre
parfois il faut juste se laisser porter
il n'y a pas de bonne guerre ou une
mauvaise bière c'est juste une question
d'essayer de goûtez moi je considère
qu'il ya une bière pour chaque personne
pour chaque palais pour chaque moment de
l'année pour chaque moment de la journée
également on peut trouver ce qu'il faut
c'est y avoir accès dans cette cave à
bières installé à bourges depuis deux
ans la mousse s'exprime sous toutes ses
faveurs
le berrichon un pari de passionnés un
lieu où brasseur amateur a confirmé se
rencontre aussi pour échanger
quand les gens poussent la porte c'est
vraiment pour découvrir des choses alors
effectivement on va partir sur les
basiques au début parce qu'on a un peu
peur et après effectivement avec les
conseils on arrive toujours à trouver
des choses qui vont être entre
guillemets complémentaires pour pouvoir
les emmener sur d'autres bières sur des
bières qu'ils connaissent pas du moins
des saveurs différentes
il ya une multitude de palettes qui a
cliqué possible
une palette de couleurs et de saveurs
qui s'obtient toujours grâce à la même
combinaison de l'eau du malt du houblon
et des levures quatre éléments à la base
de tout bière l'ingrédient le plus
essentiel c'est le malt
il donne couleur et goût à la bière il
s'obtient par la trempe la germination
et la torréfaction des céréales la
plupart du temps l'orge parfois le blé
le seigle ou l'épeautre ou alors on a vu
la partie trompe pas là c'est la
germination c'est des germoirs quand les
gras commence à germer c'est là où il ya
l'apport d'enzymes alpha millas bêta
mais la doctrine aux limites des tags de
kannad les enzymes qui vont travailler
dans le brassage brasseur industriels et
artisanaux viennent s'approvisionner ici
aux malteries franco-suisse d'issoudun
l'entreprise transforme et céréales
depuis 1894
avec l'émergence des microbrasseries il
a fallu adapter les commandes
si la production des brasseurs
artisanaux et modeste moins de mille
hectolitres par an elle est plus
exigeante sur la qualité des matières
premières du circuit court pour un micro
brasseurs pour berrichon c'est très très
important ils veulent pas ils veulent de
l'ordre la région
malte est transformée dans la région et
ne pas faire plusieurs kilomètres pour
arriver chez eux et ça c'est très très
important pour les microbrasseurs
l'aparté on va des régionales locale et
artisanale
une fois les matières premières en stock
le brassage peut commencer
mais avant tout il faut qu'on casse et
les grains broyer le malt avant de
débuter l'empaquetage période de chauffe
de l'eau et du malt nécessaires pour
transformer la ligue donc en sucre après
rinçage et filtration des drèches il
faut reprendre l'ébullition du liquide
filtrer et c'est à ce moment que l'on
ajoute le houblon
une fois le mourre refroidi le brasseur
complète la recette avec les levures la
fermentation des buts et par là même la
production d'alcool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est en limite de champagne
berrichonne et et précis a la
particularité d'être traversés par une
sorte de d'une sableuse récit construit
sur du sable
et ce champ là à la même nature de sol
et donc c'est un sol sableux profond et
qui serait propice justement à installer
une aube lumière
francis notre idole og prend
régulièrement des nouvelles du projet
d'adrien membres de l'association
houblon de france il milite pour la
culture de nouvelles variétés de la
plante et la réintroduction des
houblonnières dans tout l'hexagone
véritable nerf de la bière le houblon
est aussi une denrée très prisée
il ya une énorme demande des brasseurs
et notamment brasseurs artisanaux
microbrasserie pour ses hauts blancs
différent beaucoup plus aromatiques qui
leur permettent d'avoir une palette
organoleptiques une palette d'arômes
beaucoup plus marquée avec des bières
traditionnelles grâce à ce petit
ingrédient en évitant de faire un ajout
adjonction d'aromates donc on peut
véritablement parler d' or vert en berry
ici même apprécié muteront spa pourrait
être dans les années à venir la première
houblonnière en berry entre le python et
les coteaux depuis 15 ans la plus
ancienne des brasseries artisanales du
berry prospère installé dans les anciens
abattoirs de sancerre la doyenne des
brasseries fait dans le rétro cuves en
cuivre et étiquettes comme à la belle
époque celle où la bière coulait à flot
alors je me suis retrouvé que ce
bâtiment à sancerre dans le milieu
viticole et puis le
puis le canton de chavignol apporté et
je me suis dit faut que je monte une
brasserie qui ressemble à une brasserie
donc c'est vrai qu'au lieu d'acheter des
tanks à lait de bricoler j'ai acheté une
machine qui ressemble à une vraie
brasserie etc est en cuivre c'est un peu
aussi pour ça pour respecter
l'appellation aussi pour pour avoir une
image de marque pour moi c'est bien mais
pour l'ensemble la brasserie la cense
airways a misé sur une installation
automatisée et une fabrication de bière
à l'allemande
un choix innovant à l'époque pour
anticiper aussi les critiques des
industriels face à l'émergence des
petits brasseurs les grands groupes
pousse de plus en plus pour un
encadrement strict de la fabrication une
idée qui ne passe pas chez les artisans
quand je suis arrivé ici on m'a dit
remettra pas le mot cancer sur une
bobine donc c'est bien ça les limes à
l'image l'image qu'ils étaient
représentées c'était de la bibine
maintenant je ne veux pas dire que la
bière est tenue au niveau du vin mais on
a autant de travail à savoir faire et c
c'est tout cet apport de d'éducation de
la clientèle afin de la clientèle wii
qui a amené à redorer le blason de la
bière et dont les industriels profitent
aujourd'hui maintenant alors c'est vrai
que c'est eux qui ont fait tourner
brasseurs de france qui continue mais on
a été des représentants et c'est une
c'est nous qui l'aurons avoir mené la
belle image que la bière commence à
avoir aujourd'hui dans l'indre les
doyens ce sont les baies l'on installé
en 2004 au pied des malteries d'issoudun
il tient un bar brasserie pendant huit
ans avant de déménager à villedieu sur
indre
aujourd'hui ils militent pour leur
indépendance ont fait pas le même métier
nous ont fait la bonne bière eux ces
génies du marketing seront vos défendent
c'est une liberté de création
peddle bloquer une liberté d'appelation
ce qu'on veut défendre aussi c'est s'est
fait complice installé avec du moment
qu'on a prouvé nos capacités c'est pour
défendre les intérêts des petits
brasseurs face aux industriels que naît
le syndicat des brasseurs indépendants
en avril
les fédérations nationales pour concéder
aussi les nouveaux arrivants et le berry
n'est pas en reste
la loi sur arnon la trinquette et la
benjamine des brasseries berrichonne
eloi a fait le choix du bio comme
beaucoup des nouveaux installés et les
contraintes restent pourtant les mêmes
puisqu'il va toucher la bière en fait tu
dois être très propre quand un mec et
lumière ça
juste hériterait du fait donc qui sera
très très bon pour le développement de
ces bactéries des nouveaux locaux déjà
trop étroit pour l'ambition de notre
jeune brasseur bientôt il faudra
construire un bâtiment pour stocker la
production à peine installé déjà un oeil
sur l'avenir avec sa compagne
agricultrice ils ont décidé de combiner
leurs activités
à terme on voudrait
on voudrait cultiver les céréales pour
la brasserie on a commencé à planter du
houblon tout ça donc on voudrait c'est
d'avoir une démarche globale sur le
bière sont des seuils de
d'être le plus maître de ce que l'on
fait de savoir le mieux possible ce
qu'on transforme
après on pourra probablement pas tout
avoir en local mais on va essayer de
maximiser si on arrive à produire le
large de base et le transforme et
nous-mêmes n'aura déjà 80% du 80 % de la
matière première qui sera d'ici un
projet de ferme brasserie pour proposer
un produit 100% local une belle idée de
plus en plus prisé par les jeunes
brasseurs devenir professionnel sans
avoir jamais brasse et c'est quand même
un gros pari parce qu'on s'est passé
comme si on voulait faire pâtissier sans
avoir jamais fait de cadeau vraiment
c'est vraiment la brasserie c'est
vraiment la cuisine c'est vraiment mais
vraiment très très proches
et c'est chez lui que matthieu brasse
encore aujourd'hui entre deux cuissons
du loup une séance de dégustation des
précédents brasse en simple aux couleurs
douces un peu rouge couleur qui
m'aideront comme ça que de carbonatation
avant d'avoir une expérience de
brasseurs faut avoir une expérience de
dix heures de théâtre
toutes proportions gardées ou pas ça
dépend d'où on vient et et après je
pense qu'il faut aimer la cuisine
simplement c'est vraiment du c'est la
cuisine donc on a dit on a des
ingrédients qu'on peut pas trop sur
lesquels on peut pas trop influent et
après c'est juste un mix on dit voilà je
vais être un petit peu de samedi
peut-être un petit peu de ça et c'est
comme quand on fait une recette de
cuisine c'est exactement pareil
en plus d'être une passion la bière est
devenue son métier
aujourd'hui c'est chez thomas mousseau
de la brasserie où chalon qu'il fait ses
armes
installé depuis huit ans en berry ce
brasseur microbiologiste de formation à
partager son expérience dans un livre un
guide à l'usagé du brasseur amateur j'ai
commencé aussi en étant brasseur amateur
ce qui donne
et quand même des bases pour écrire un
livre là-dessus puisque embrasseurs
embrasse père matters on touche à plein
de façons de faire différentes donc on a
testé des centaines de recettes de berre
et ça je pense que ça donne quand même
une une idée de ce que c'est que
brassage amateurs qui est différent du
brassage propose des recettes et des
astuces
recueilli par une journaliste berruyères
un ouvrage médine berry avec l'idée de
rendre accessible à tous cette pratique
handycam des gaulois les gaulois aime la
bière fument la cervoise si on l'appelle
plus comme ça il ya une mode et en même
temps je pense que ça va durer parce que
le fait mais on va tout le contexte
écologique y est on se rend bien compte
que le fait de faire les choses à la
maison coûte beaucoup moins cher
et puis aussi c'est de convivialité on
est entre potes on a décidé d'acheter un
peu de matériel et on va se mettre dans
son garage et on va fabriquer notre
bière on peut arriver en soirée avec un
bouquet de fleurs mais c'est quand même
plus place je trouve d'arrivée avec sa
bière maison
plusieurs sites internet proposent déjà
des kits pour réaliser sa bière maison
la cervoise a donc de beaux jours devant
elle
si les français boivent moins d'alcool
il cherche la qualité auprès des
brasseurs artisanaux en berry
l'engouement pour le breuvage ne fait
que commencer
voilà moi elle a toujours appris à
permet de tout se réunir autour d'une
passion qu'elle a d'ailleurs au china
tout le monde a déjà vu une guerre dans
sa vie comme du vin et tout le monde a
envie d'apprendre tout le monde a une
marge de progression considérable
c'est l'intérêt juste de faire de la
bière c'est de la beauté
[Musique]